[Musique]
dans l'east end la vie
elle s'appelle louise de la vallière
madame de montespan madame de maintenon
ou encore mademoiselle de fontanges leur
nom vous dit forcément quelque chose ce
sont quelques-unes des maîtresses de
louis xiv on les appelle des favorites
car elles ont vécu au plus près du plus
grand des rois de france alors suivons
les et relisons l'histoire à travers
leur regard vous verrez cela change tout
[Musique]
louis xiv c'est quelqu'un qui veut
éblouir le roi soleil
[Musique]
tout lui était bon pourvu que ce fussent
des femmes son obsession pour les femmes
ne supporte plus
[Musique]
on délimite voit la relation incestueuse
et on ne partage pas sa femme avec son
frère
quel culot cette madame de montespan
c'était plus fort que moi j'ai giflé
[Musique]
toute la cour cris à l'empoisonnement
je suis cocu appelons les choses par
leur nom
c'est une synthèse de dsk et de
mitterrand
[Musique]
nous sommes à paris devant le musée du
louvre l'un des monuments les plus
visités au monde c'est ici que notre
histoire commence c'était il y a trois
cent soixante ans exactement en 1653 oui
14 à 15 ans il lui ici avec sa mère
officiellement c'est lui le roi mais en
réalité c'est elle qui gouvernent
aujourd'hui un jour particulièrement
important dans la vie du jeune
adolescent puisqu'il va perdre sa
virginité et aussi incroyable que cela
puisse paraître c'est sa propre mère qui
va tout orchestré pourquoi comment je
vous retrouve tout de suite au xviie
siècle dans la chambre du roi là où la
petite histoire rencontre la grande
[Musique]
voici la pièce où louis xiv va devenir
un homme sa mère la reine anne
d'autriche et d'ailleurs justement en
train de choisir parmi ces dames de
compagnie celle qui aura la tâche
délicate de dépuceler le jeune roi
vous madame des bovins je sais votre
coeur et votre dévouement
[Applaudissements]
on voit une madame de beauvais ma foi
ses ravissantes certains les bornes mais
j'aurais aimé qu'elle soit davantage
qu'elle est davantage le visage piqueté
par là des rôles ce qui était le cas
j'aurais rajouté une petite vingtaine
d'années car elle avait 40 ans
lorsqu'elle fut chargé de veiller aux
puces cache du roi
elle sélectionne pas parmi toutes les
jolies femmes de la cour elle prend au
contraire la plus laide qui est la
baronne de beauvais et capte la borne
yes à qui il manquait comme son nom
l'indiqué un oeil pourquoi la plus laide
parce qu'il fallait quand même pas que
le petit plus s'attacher à cette femme
qu'il en fasse un objet
pour apprendre à aimer mais surtout pas
de sentiment
madame de beauvais est une femme de
confiance et d'expérience avec elle
c'est certain louis aura la meilleure
des initiations veiller sur lui
comme adam et eve nous illustres parents
nous étudierons tous
nous étudierons avec application comment
les femmes sont en fait il plaisir
qu'elles peuvent donner venez découvrir
la merveilleuse et de la vie
le dépucelage du roi est une véritable
affaire d'état
dans le couloir attenant à la chambre du
jeune louis xiv les courtisans
s'impatiente et retiennent leur souffle
c'est une affaire d'état la royauté est
une est une tradition qui doit se
transmettre de de père en fils c'est une
importance c'est la france on n'est pas
seulement dans dans dans la personne
humaine le le roi représente la nation
toute entière est l idée que le roi plus
à son tour mettre au monde un héritier
eh bien c'est ce qui compte le plus
c'est une affaire d'état parce que il
est le roi et son devoir c'est de
permettre la perpétuation de la dynastie
donc il faut absolument pouvoir
s'assurer que le roi aura un héritier
[Musique]
il y a
mais que ça même du che
[Musique]
alors si la reine anne d'autriche
s'occupe à ce point de l'éducation
sexuelle de son fils c'est parce
qu'elles gardent en mémoire la cuisante
expérience de sa propre nuit de noces
avec lui tu rêves son mari
[Musique]
un d'autriche a depuis longtemps été
négligé par son mari et elle tenait à
s'assurer effectivement que louis xiv
soit initié correctement aux choses de
l'amour
je me souviens de ma nuit de noces avec
feu monnaies pour louis xiii nous ne
connaissions rien aux choses de l'amour
ce fut épouvantable
on dit allez savoir qu'entre là le
premier en une noce et la deuxième nuit
neuf mois se sont écoulés c'est quand
même quelque chose de terrible
[Musique]
lorsque madame de beauvais a terminé ce
qu'elle devait faire avec le jeune louis
la reine chose incroyable va devant
toute la cour annoncer la bonne nouvelle
notre roi
lorient
les instituts de sa majesté fut extrême
madame de mauvais
d'épuiser madame de prouver ses crocs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui quand une maman est très
proche de son enfant peut-être trop
proche de son gamin on aura tendance à
dire qu'elle se comporte et ce n'est pas
du tout nos jours bien sûr comme une
mère juive c'est la maman juive qui
s'occupe du gamin du début jusqu'à la
fin même mari elle continue de
s'immiscer au sein du couple est bien
anne d'autriche c'est cela elle va
s'occuper très tôt de tout ce qui
concerne son fils l'alimentation le
protocole le poids et la sexualité elle
veut tout contrôler et compris la
première qui fera de louer un homme
anne d'autriche est une femme comblée
son fils est maintenant capable
d'assurer de façon certaine la
continuité de la dynastie han bonne
pédagogue madame de beauvais a donc
réussi sa mission d'ailleurs pour cela
elle va être grassement récompensés
elle va être curieusement payé
d'ailleurs puisque on ne va pas lui
donner quelques dizaines de milliers de
livres pour avoir
un déniaisé le petit louis on va la
payer j'allais dire en briques non pas
en briques mais en pierre parce qu'on
avait un stock de pierres au louvre qui
n'avait pas été utilisé
eh bien on lui offre cette énorme stock
de pierres pour qu'elle puisse se
construire son hôtel de beauvais à paris
grâce à madame de beauvais louis xiv est
devenu ce que l'on peut appeler un homme
à femmes dotée d'un appétit sexuel
insatiable
ainsi le jeune roi passe son adolescence
dans l'insouciance la plus totale
[Musique]
acceptez-vous leroy
joie oui oui alors avancé
[Musique]
et je crois que louis xiv a besoin qu'on
le regarde avec intérêt avec gourmandise
avec envie louis xiv a besoin d'être
désiré tel le roi des abeilles avec tout
un essaim de jolies femmes autour de lui
qui ne révèle qu'une seule chose c'est
conquérir le coeur du roi il est assez
misogyne mais en même temps c'est un
passionné des femmes un grand amoureux
il faut se souvenir aussi qu'au xviie
siècle les distractions sont rares il ya
la guerre et vous parlez d'une
distraction il ya la chasse il ya et il
ya le sexe dont il ya quand même pas
quantité de choses à faire le soir au
coin du feu
[Musique]
si anne d'autriche est omniprésente dans
l'éducation de louis xiv il n'en va pas
de même pour son fils cadet philippe que
tout le monde appelle monsieur en effet
la reine va donner à ses enfants deux
éducations totalement différente
c'est vrai que philippe jeu les éduquer
différemment c'est un enfant sensible
doux avec une certaine féminité il est à
l'opposé de son frère
la reine aime ses deux enfants
évidemment le petit louis et l'hostis
philippe mais naturellement avec une
préférence pour les néo celui qui est
appelé à porter la couronne
toute l'attention de la reine se porte
donc sur louis xiv au détriment bien sûr
de son fils cadet philippe je pense que
le malheureux monsieur a été quelque peu
mais sur la touche qu'il a été quelque
peu délaissé il était tout simplement ce
qu'on appelle la route ce coup c'est
terrible et une roue de secours et je
pense d'ailleurs que l'éducation n'était
pas la même l'un a reçu l'éducation d'un
roi l'autre n'a reçu que l'éducation
d'assaut bout il ya une jalousie qui
s'instaure les deux enfants sont élevés
ensemble en même temps ce sont des
rivaux sciemment et des tout petits on
va écarter et déresponsabiliser philippe
le jeune frère du roi il va développer
donc une une personnalité un peu
atypique assez immature capricieuse
l'aimera se farder qu'il s'attachera
beaucoup du meilleur très précieuse à
son habillement
en effet dès son plus jeune âge philippe
le frère du roi aime se travestir
il ne se résout pas abandonner les robes
qu'il portait enfants ce qui ne sera pas
anodin l'éducation aura une incidence
incroyable sur la la vie voire la
sexualité l'un louis xiv est un homme
car un appétit incroyable et a un goût
des femmes démesurée monsieur est un
homme beaucoup plus fêtards que 1014 et
qui lui se comptera davantage sur
l'homosexualité et cela louis xiv ne va
pas le supporter
ne peut plus vous voir derrière les
portes avec des garçons pour fondement
je cachais vous
vous derrière les portes avec les filles
[Musique]
deux garçons et même maman une éducation
totalement différente à l'un pour
l'autre deux parcours différents
anne d'autriche et rassurer louis xiv
aime les femmes il sera donc capable
d'assurer la descendance du royaume elle
peut à présent veiller à l'éducation
politique de son fils afin qu'il
devienne un grand roi un d'autriche
continuera à gouverner la france pendant
encore quelques années en compagnie du
cardinal mazarin premier ministre du
royaume en attendant louis apprend son
métier de roi mais il ne va pas tarder à
comprendre qu'un souverain aussi
puissant soit il ne fait pas toujours ce
qu'il veut
nous sommes en 1658 louis xiv à 20 ans
c'est un beau jeune homme et il va pour
la première fois de sa vie tomber
amoureux
à cette époque la france est en guerre
en vue d'annexer le territoire de la
flandre qui appartient pour le moment
aux espagnols
ce soir là le cardinal mazarin est
inquiet alors que les combats font rage
louis xiv est tombé gravement malade les
médecins diagnostiquent une fièvre
typhoïde comment vous sentez-vous aussi
alors il tombe malade c'est une grande
inquiétude
à paris au prix pour
la santé du roi et alors que louis xiv
tremble de fièvre le coup de foudre va
se produire sur
[Musique]
là il tombe sous le charme de pied est
bien de la fameuse petite marie mancini
[Musique]
mazarin a fait venir d'italie toute sa
tribu deux nièces toutes les petites
mazzarri net qui était de jolies petites
femmes d'ailleurs la petite marie
mancini était peut-être la plus mignonne
en effet le cheveux très noirs l'oeil
très vif très fine traite presque maigre
d'ailleurs on dit qu'elle avait des
papes deux héros ont tellement ses
jambes rétais landes était élancé et
louis xiv la rencontre croiser son
regard il tombe sous le charme
de retour à paris louis xiv remis sur
pied n'a d'yeux que pour marie mancini
et pense avoir trouvé la femme de sa vie
les deux jeunes gens ne se quittent plus
et rêve de se marier
souvent dit que ça avait été comment
dirais-je platonique essentiellement
platonique on ne pourra pas voter de
l'idée que vif comme il était et chaude
comme elle pouvait l'être cette petite
italienne il ne se soit rien passé
physiquement entre est incontestable et
ils vont s'aimer
petit foyer
[Musique]
il tombe amoureux de marie médecine et
il est loin de se douter que la
politique va se mêler des affaires de
coeur
car la reine mère et son premier
ministre voit d'un très mauvais oeil
l'idylle entre louis xiv et marie
mancini
ils vont désormais tout faire pour la
faire cesser et la jeune marie va tomber
de haut
elle est convaincue qu'elle va devenir
reine bien entendu jusqu'à ce que tonton
mazarin réagi sur dix ans de l'enfant il
en est pas question le roi de france
doit elle pas épousé une de mes nièces
comme ça ça ne va rien apporter au
royaume sacem sens du royaume de mazarin
qui envisage tout de suite des mariages
politique destin de louis xiv était de
se lier à une famille royale étrangères
et maryvonne ci n'avait pas sa place au
sein de ce dispositif
la rupture est inévitable
marie mancini est chassée de la cour le
roi les adieux avec son bien-aimé leroy
sont déchirants
vous êtes le roi
et vous pleurez
[Musique]
vous avez 20 ans vous aimez une jeune
femme que vous trouvez splendide que
vous trouvez superbe et vous ne pouvez
pas rester avec elle pour raison d'état
c'est incompréhensible dans la tête d'un
jeune homme de 20 ans louis xiv via
louis xiv quand ils renoncent à marie
mansigné parce que il a compris que la
raison d'état lui interdit d'épouser
cette cette jeune fille il lui a promis
qu'elle deviendrait rennes et il est
obligé évidemment de revenir sur sa
parole
marie mancini quittent la cour louis xiv
doit se résoudre à épouser une autre
femme une certaine marie thérèse
d'autriche fille du roi d'espagne et une
jeune femme qu'il ne connaît pas qu'il
n'aime pas et qu'ils n'aimera jamais
tournoi qu il est il doit se conformer à
la raison d'état plus forte que les
élans du coeur
[Musique]
1660 c'est le mariage de louis xiv et de
marie thérèse d'autriche à
saint-jean-de-luz à la frontière
espagnole un mariage royal certes qui
scelle la paix entre la france et
l'espagne mais très vite l'infante
d'espagne va comprendre que son rôle à
la cour sera pour le moins limité le
principal rôle d'une reine de france
pour louis xiv est de donner à la
couronne des héritiers elle a un rôle
pardonnez-moi de potiche on lui demande
simplement d'être là car le roi
catholique se doit d'être mariée dès le
départ la nouvelle reine marie thérèse
ne fait pas vraiment l'unanimité
et vous 14 en la voyant est assez déçu
alors on rassure le 14 en disant que
mais non c'est c'est le costume qu'elle
est petite blonde un peu boulotte
elle parle mal le français très mal
autres on pose la question
traditionnelle voulez vous épousez si
dit-elle en espagnol car elle parlera
toujours l'espagnol ne fera pratiquement
jamais aucun effort pour parler français
marie thérèse
leroy a fait semblant de la trouvais
belle et toute la france derrière lui or
elle est terne elle est effacée elle est
sinistre
[Musique]
le caractère de marie thérèse d'autriche
va très vite posé problème à louis xiv
car pour lui une reine se doit d'être
élégante flamboyante avec de l'esprit or
marie thérèse et toul inverse elle n'a
pas les toffes d'une reine elle fait
peut-être un petit peu bonne femme
effacée déjà et elle restera effacés
pendant tout son règne et ça fait le
désespoir du roi cette chose là
ainsi la relation entre les deux époux
va se limiter au seul devoir conjugal
que louis xiv assurera avec une
véritable conscience professionnelle il
aura avec marie thérèse d'autriche six
enfants
louis xiv à cela s'est très rapidement
de cet homme
en effet le roy préfère s'amuser danser
et passer du bon temps avec des jeunes
femmes de la cour
[Musique]
mais ce comportement insouciant et
volage du roi agace profondément sa mère
anne d'autriche qui ne va pas se priver
de lui dire
seulement la reine mère va bientôt le
regretté
le 9 mars 1661 mazarin celui qui jusqu'à
présent gouverner le pays aux côtés
d'anne d'autriche moeurs
l'occasion est donc toute trouvée pour
louis xiv qui peut désormais prendre en
main son destin de roi dès le lendemain
le 10 mars 1661 il annonce à ses
ministres et à sa mère comment il entend
à l'avenir gouverner le pays seul en
monarque absolu c'est ce que l'histoire
retiendra de lui aujourd'hui la face du
théâtre change
jusqu'à ce jour j'ai laissé gouverner
mais à faire un ministre sous la
direction de feu le cardinal mazarin
désormais je règnerait seul
seulement anne d'autriche sa mère ne
l'entend pas de cette oreille oui
gouverner
c'est exactement ce que je compte faire
enfin oui vous n'avez aucune expérience
du pouvoir
la guitare oui cela vous connaît la
chasse et les balles et vegeta
que savez-vous de l'état
c'est mon choix je décide je suis le roi
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour ma mère
elle a beaucoup fait pour moi je ne peux
le nier mais désormais il est temps
qu'elle cède la place
à l'autriche qui a du mal à voir son
fils grandir tente par tous les moyens
de le dissuader de gouverner seul
guimond empêchera
en vain alors madame vous me forcerait à
vous exclure vous aussi
oui
si nos mères pour le bien du royaume
j'oserais
ayant voilà c'est fait
désormais anne d'autriche n'a plus aucun
rôle politique elle se sent trahie
je suis très en colère j'ai tout fait
pour que mon fils devienne aux plus
grands rois de france et voilà qu'il me
congédie comme la dernière des
malpropres je trouve ça profondément
injuste
oui ce jour-là louis xiv devient le
monarque absolu que l'on connaît doté de
tous les pouvoirs
comme l'on dit il vient de couper le
cordon maternelle mais il va se séparer
de sa mère
pas manu militari mais presque c'est à
dire qu'il va couper les ponts mais un
petit peu comme il faut le faire pour se
libérer de les entraves quelqu'un lui
avait fait peser pendant toute son
enfance et de son adolescence je pense
que louis xiv à 22 ans effectivement
décide de se détacher de la tutelle
maternelle et de tous ceux qui
l'entourent pour enfin aval le destin du
pays est le sien de manière totalement
autonome
maintenant louis xiv est seul maître à
bord et peut faire ce que bon lui semble
quitte à provoquer le scandale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est au printemps 761 dans le château
de fontainebleau une résidence royale
située à 55 kilomètres au sud de paris
que louis xiv va provoquer un scandale
la rumeur dit qu'il aurait eu une
liaison avec un membre de sa propre
famille et pas n'importe qui sa
belle-soeur la femme de son frère
henriette d'angleterre pour mieux
comprendre ce qui s'est passé suivez moi
cet après-midi dans le cabinet du jeu du
château la famille royale est réuni il y
à l'ats anne d'autriche la reine mère en
pleine discussion avec marie thérèse sa
belle fille les pousses du roi celui ci
est installé à la table de jeu face à
son frère philippe dit monsieur de deux
ans son cadet
mais voici henriette celle par qui le
scandale arrive à 17 ans à peine elle
vient d'épouser philippe or c'est de
notoriété publique
philippe préfère les hommes
alors henriette tombe amoureuse de louis
xiv et c'est réciproque les regards
qu'ils s'échangent ne trompe personne
ils passent de plus en plus de temps
ensemble et la rumeur grandit
il aura suffi de quelques secondes pour
que le roi tombe amoureux de sa belle
soeur
il faut dire qu'en rillettes
d'angleterre a un charme fou jeune belle
discrète et intelligente de surcroît mai
à la cour son rapprochement avec le roi
passe mal
le tout finit par se savoir surtout dans
un lieu où tout le monde écoute aux
portes et lorsque l'on apprend que louis
xiv mari a une relation avec henriette
d'angleterre c'est un drame épouvantable
il ya eu entre les deux un amour un
amour sincère avec cette grosse
difficulté quand même savoir que là on
est dans un adultère un peu compliqué
c'est quand même la femme de son frère
ont des limites dans la relation
incestueuse
et quand le principal intéressé philippe
s'aperçoit qu'il est trompé son sang ne
fait qu'un tour
[Musique]
toute la courbe russe du fait que louis
xiv ème sa belle soeur alors monsieur
évidemment et courroucé de ça il va
immédiatement se plaindre anne
d'autriche horrifié qui réclame tout de
suite la rupture de son fils avec
henriette d'angleterre
elle a 17 ans le roi lui en a 22
discrètement louis et henriette se
retrouvent dans les jardins de
fontainebleau à l'abri des regards
malgré tout la cour commence à jaser et
anne d'autriche la reine-mère bois cette
liaison d'un très mauvais oeil
un d'autriche aura beau sermonné son
fils louis xiv ne va pas pour autant
cessé de fréquenter henriette
reste à savoir si l'amour entre les deux
jeunes amants a été consommée et là
dessus tout le monde n'est pas d'accord
entre eux il n'y aura jamais rien on en
est quasi sûr ne sera pas sa détresse
mais il y aura simplement
d'amitié amoureuse très très poussée je
suis convaincu d'une relation complice
et coupable entre henriette d'angleterre
et 2014 moi je suis assez enclin à
croire qu'à partir jean louis xiv pose
les yeux sur une jolie femme ils ne
posent pas que les eu
pour faire taire le scandale
leroy et henriette d'angleterre ont une
idée faire croire à tout la cour que
leur idylle a cessé et voilà le
stratagème qui l'ont imaginé la parade
ça va être la théorie du paravent on lui
impose la petite louise de la vallière
pour mettre entre eux henriette et lui
pour sauver les apparences et ont dit à
louis attention maintenant vos
plaisanteries c'est terminé montrez vous
êtes amoureux de mademoiselle de la
vallière sinon il vous en coûtera
et
je m'appelle louise de la vallière j'ai
17 ans je suis demoiselle de compagnie
d'henriette angleterre la belle soeur du
roi depuis quelques temps je vois bien
que le roi me regarde avec insistance à
m'intimider il faut dire qu'il est bel
homme est très séduisant mais que se
passe-t-il eh bien il tombe amoureux de
louise de la vallière au détriment
d'henriette et bien le 14 à être
lui-même pris à son propre piège
puisqu'il va tomber amoureux du paravent
et délaissé la complice de ce tour
henriette d'angleterre
henriette délaissé par le roi retrouve
sa place aux côtés de son mari
philippe et sa mère anne d'autriche ont
de quoi être satisfaits
le scandale est étouffé
la liaison entre louis xiv et henriette
d'angleterre n'aura duré que le temps
d'un printemps
et le destin de cette femme connaîtra
une issue tragique dix ans plus tard en
1670 puisqu'elle va mourir à 26 ans dans
d'atroces souffrances après avoir
ingurgité une tasse de chicorée
à l'époque aucun médecin ne sera capable
d'expliquer les causes de cette mort
subite alors une question est sur toutes
les lèvres ce qu'on n'a pas tout
henriette d'angleterre
toute la cour cris à l'empoisonnement
alors les regards se portent vers son
mari et certains de ses favoris et on
vise le cheval de rennes qui était donc
l'amant de monsieur et qui avait une
haine farouche envers en quelque sorte
sa rivale
philippe le mari trompé at-il donc
demandé à son amant le chevalier de
lorraine d'empoisonner henriette
d'angleterre cette question les
historiens se la sont posée pendant 300
ans jusqu'à ce que le mystère soit enfin
levé d'après le procès-verbal de
l'autopsié les médecins aujourd'hui
qu'on examinait ce cas estime qu' il ya
double terre est morte d'une
maladie
légumes quelque chose d' avoisinant mais
d'une mort naturelle
[Musique]
retour en 1661
louis xiv parvient difficilement à
cacher sa passion pour sa nouvelle
conquête louise de la vallière
à tel point que sa mère anne d'autriche
pieuse et des votes s'agace de ce
comportement qu'elle juge libertin
que je suis aussi allé pour que mon fils
se comporte de la sorte
son obsession pour les femmes je ne la
supporte plus
[Musique]
louis xiv n'écoutera pas sa mère quoi
qu'elle pense il l'a décidé
louise de la vallière fait désormais
partie de sa vie mais il manque encore
quelque chose au roi pour assouvir sa
soif de grandeur et de pouvoir un
château à la mesure de ses ambitions et
dans lequel il pourra vivre comme bon
lui semble et ce château ce sera
versailles à cette époque le bâtiment
ressemble encore à cela un petit
pavillon de chasse perdu au milieu des
marais
mais louis xiv veut transformer ce
bâtiment pour en faire le plus grand et
le plus beau château jamais construit
alors pendant 50 ans plusieurs milliers
d'hommes vont travailler sur ce chantier
titanesque
[Musique]
je crois que louis xiv a passé sa vie à
vouloir laisser une trace avec les
enfants qu'il faisait successivement des
quantités d'enfants c'est une trace sont
des traces qu'il laisse avec le pouvoir
qu'il prend les guerres qu'il fait les
frontières qu'il a grandi et avec le
château de versailles qu'il va
construire et qu'il voulait comme étant
le plus beau château de la chrétienté
louis xiv a une idée très précise du
château qu'il souhaite alors ils
surveillent les travaux lui-même jusque
dans les moindres détails
louis xiv multiplie les visites de
chantier et il contrôlait tous des
grands plafond jusqu au dessin
desjardins et jusqu'à l'entourage
parfois d'une même d'une serrure
on a une lettre très belle de colbert à
louis xiv et colbert la forme de
l'avancement des travaux du château de
versailles et lui dit mme jusqu'où je
dois vous mettre au courant pouvoir pour
ne pas vous ennuyer c'est un peu comme
aujourd'hui est-ce que je vous mets en
copie du mail de tous les mails
cinquante mille mètres carrés de
plancher plus de deux mille fenêtres 700
pièces 67 escaliers 800 hectares de parc
20 km de routes deux cent mille arbres
un château digne des plus grands
empereurs de l'antiquité
[Musique]
il fallait en mettre plein la vue louis
xiv c'est quelqu'un qui veut éblouir le
roi soleil sans nom il le porte bien
mais il veut et blue y est c'est pour ça
que avec les femmes il veut que ce soit
toujours de très jolies femmes des
femmes éblouissante
et puis la sonnerie sur le château
et sans nul doute la célèbre galerie des
glaces connu dans le monde entier elle
sera achevée tardivement en 1684 une
pièce gigantesque de 73 mètres de long
10 mètres de large douze mètres de haut
qui comporte 357 miroir dix sept
fenêtres et 20 lustres une salle
splendide symbole de la grandeur 2014
qui as
larry
[Musique]
au début des travaux la cour vite au
château de saint germain en laye l'une
des résidences royales
et c'est ici que l'amour entre louis xiv
et louise de la vallière va prendre
toute sa dimension
[Musique]
louise devient alors la première vraie
maîtresse en titre du roi
je
il lui fera quatre enfants sans aucun
scrupule
louis xiv donc est très amoureux de
louise l'avenir lui fait plusieurs
enfants en même temps qu il en fait
aussi à l'appel
parfois d'ailleurs ironie de l'histoire
louise accouchera en même temps que
l'épousé légitime marie thérèse
d'autriche mais la reine accepte cette
situation sans sourciller
du moins on ne lui demande pas son avis
va souffrir toute sa vie évidemment du
comportement du roi marie thérèse
d'autriche est une femme qui a été
souvent meurtrie parfois blessé mais
toujours malheureuse
un d'autriche la mère du roi est plus qu
excédé par l'attitude pour le moins
désinvolte de louis xiv envers son
épouse une dernière fois dans un dernier
souffle elle va tenter de remettre son
fils dans le droit chemin
[Musique]
20 janvier 1666 palais du louvre la
reine anne d'autriche est sur son lit de
mort terrassé par un cancer
avant de rendre l'âme elle aurait
demandé à son fils de lui promettre de
mener désormais une vie rangée
je crois que vous force à montrer je ne
peux supporter celui que vous devenez
jury
je ne veux rien vous promettre que je
puisse tenir
même si le roi est abattu par le chagrin
louis n'a pas promis de devenir fidèles
bien au contraire car maintenant que la
reine mère est morte il n'y a plus
personne pour lui tenir tête
dorénavant louis n'aura plus besoin de
cacher ses amours pire il va les
afficher ostensiblement au moment même
où une nouvelle femme entre en scène
[Musique]
retour au château de saint germain en
laye
[Musique]
tous les jours le levé du roi donne lieu
à un protocole réglé au millimètre
à 8h30 toute la cour doit assister à ce
cérémonial qui montre un peu plus encore
la puissance du roi
la journée 2014 est réglé comme une
horloge comme une véritable pièce de
théâtre qui se reproduit jour après jour
de son lever jusqu'au coucher du roi il
a été capable de sacraliser sa propre
personne louis xiv a réussi à faire de
lui un dieu vivant il s'est fait
respecter et en se faisant respecter il
s'est fait craindre
tous les matins à la cour c'est le même
rituel plusieurs dizaines de personnes
assistent dans un silence religieux au
levé du roi
cardinaux ambassadeurs ministres prince
du valais sans oublier les dames de
compagnie de la reine atout charme de la
cour auquel le roi bien évidemment
jamais insensible
et parmi les dames de compagnie de la
reine qui assistent au levé du roi
il y en a une à la beauté diabolique qui
va marquer l'histoire de france
qui peut vraiment se comparer à moi
françoise athénaïs de montespan seule ma
famille est issu d'une noblesse aussi
ancien presque aucun amm en france ne
serait digne de mon rang sauf peut-être
le roi en personne
[Musique]
madame de montespan est sans doute une
des plus belles femmes de la cour quand
louis xiv a le bonheur de croiser son
regard je ne sais pas moi si on veut une
comparaison aujourd'hui ça aurait été
peut-être claudia schiffer temps tel
temps elle est radieuse sentait les
temps elle est belle de partout de la
poitrine des yeux du petit mollet bien
galbées enfin ça c'est un bonheur d'un
jeu dereix le physique de marilyn monroe
et l'esprit de simone de beauvoir quand
elle vient à versailles
elle vient pour devenir maîtresse du roi
elle ne vient pas par hasard elle a une
idée en tête une seule devenir la
première dans le coeur de louis xiv
pour conquérir le roi la montespan en
femme calculatrice un plan prendre la
place de louise de la vallière maîtresse
en titre et cette dernière qui croient
en son amitié ne voit rien venir
ma chère amie louise à deux problèmes
elle est follement amoureuse du roi qui
était perdu mon amoureux d'elle et elle
me croit sa meilleure amie
le malade de la vallière effectivement
fait venir à versailles madame de
montespan étant loin de se douter que
celle ci allait prendre sa place dans le
coeur du roi
pour séduire le roi athénaïs de
montespan a2a tout son charme indéniable
bien entendu mais surtout beaucoup
d'esprit
il est vrai que le plus grand charme de
madame de montespan ce que fait sa
singularité c'est surtout son esprit
c'est une manière de faire des
plaisanteries très piquante on appelait
ça d'ailleurs des petites piques au tri
de madame de montespan et au siècle du
bel esprit cette raillerie cette
plaisanterie pratiquer avec élégance
était une arme absolument redoutable
depuis quelques temps sa majesté la
reine tente d'impressionner le roi par
ses souliers à hauts talons en espagne
cependant elle n'a pas appris comment
ils ont fait pour marcher avec
[Rires]
j'ai toujours peur d'ennuyer le roi
vous
je suis sûr que vous le feriez rire
et c'est à force de piqué de
plaisanterie que madame de montespan va
parvenir à séduire louis xiv regardez
comment elle va s'y prendre
pour s'attirer les faveurs du roi
demain sujet j'ai entendu seulement
jusqu'ici que vous étiez la plus belle
femme de france
si c'est la vérité cyr ne devez vous pas
vos sujets et aimer cette femme
autre réponse montre de l'esprit
[Musique]
mais peu de bienséance je n'ai jamais
adressée à dieu qu'une prière
fait de moi une honorable personnes mais
jamais une femme honorable
[Musique]
vous avez vu la façon dont il me regarde
et je pense que j'ai toutes mes chances
quel culot cette madame de montespan
quel regard elle est sublime c'est
indéniable oui j'avoue
je ne suis point sensible à ses charmes
et ce qui devait arriver arriva je suis
tombé éperdument amoureux de madame de
montespan
[Musique]
cette nouvelle liaison entre louis xiv
et madame de montespan va naître au
printemps 1667 sur un champ de bataille
louis xiv est une nouvelle fois en
guerre contre l'espagne partis à la
conquête des pays bas etc pendant les
combats que la relation avec la marquise
de montespan et consommer pour la
première fois une liaison torride et
passionnel
[Musique]
la marquise de montespan et donc la
nouvelle maîtresse royale
seulement il y a un problème comme le
roi elle aussi est marié il faut donc
garder le secret pour là encore éviter
le scandale
[Musique]
l'histoire se répète pour mademoiselle
de la vallière une fois de plus elle est
utilisée comme paravent pour cacher une
nouvelle maîtresse du roi
émanant de la vallière va jouer le rôle
de paravent le roi donc s'affichant avec
la nouvelle de la vallière pendant un
certain temps alors qu'il courtise et
que tout le monde le sait madame de
montespan
officiellement le roi s'affiche donc
avec mademoiselle de la vallière et pour
le moment personne ne doit savoir qu'il
a aussi une liaison avec madame de
montespan
[Musique]
son mari non plus d'ailleurs
mais aucune crainte car le marquis de
montespan n'est pas à la cour à ce
moment là mais sur les champs de
bataille à la frontière des pyrénées
[Musique]
à son retour 11 mois plus tard le
marquis va découvrir le pot-aux-roses sa
femme a pris quelques formes et il
comprend qu'il n'y est strictement pour
rien you may d'hommes
[Musique]
l'enfant que vous semblez porter
du jour au lendemain le marquis devient
le plus grand qu'au cul du royaume
monsieur de montespan décide alors de se
venger du roi et il est une idée
machiavélique
il décide de contracter la syphilis
c'est comme une maladie sexuellement
transmissible et mortelle à l'époque
pour cela un soir il arpente les
quartiers chauds de la capitale à la
recherche d'une prostituée il va jusqu'à
fréquenté à paris les prostituées les
plus sales dans l'espoir de contracter
une maladie vénérienne de la transmettra
sa femme et que elle même la transmette
au roi louis xiv notre bus lane va quand
même moi
[Musique]
c'est mon droit je suis votre époux
le plan de monsieur de montespan a
échoué cependant le marquis n'a pas dit
son dernier mot avec beaucoup de panache
il multiplie les coups d'éclat il
commence déjà par envahir son carrosse
de corne de cerf pour montrer à tous
paris sa condition de cocu
l'homme n'a pas froid aux yeux il va
demander audience à louis xiv et faire
ce que jamais personne n'aurait osé
faire braver et provoquer le roi en
personne majesté
pourquoi tout ce noir monsieur de qui
portez vous le deuil de ma femme cire de
ma femme le deuil de votre femme je ne
comprends pas oui si
elle est mort pour moi une canaille me
la voler
outré le roi ordonne qu'on enferme le
marquis à la prison parisienne de fort
lévesque
le marquis de montespan a dépassé les
bornes
et sans oublier à qui il s'adresse
[Musique]
monsieur de montespan ne reverra jamais
sa femme leur séparation sera prononcé
quelques années plus tard
[Musique]
dès lors débarrasser de son encombrant
mari madame de montespan est une femme
totalement libre et peut désormais se
consacrer entièrement au roi louis xiv
est aux anges avec l'arrivée de la
montespan il devient polygame assumer
sous le même toit trois femmes se
partagent le coeur et le lit du roi la
marquise de montespan
mademoiselle de la vallière et
évidemment la reine marie thérèse
d'autriche le simple fait d'être marié
religieusement et d'avoir sous le même
toit conjugal d'autres femmes autorisées
à dormir avec le roi louis c'est de la
polygamie louis xiv et les femmes
c'est une synthèse de dsk et de
mitterrand parce que c'est un musée
c'est un malicieux est il bon il est
aussi
une bête de sexe c'est incontestable
et sa polygamie leroy n'hésite pas à
l'affiché surtout lorsqu'il part à la
guerre louis xiv ne se déplace jamais
sans ses femmes
sur les routes lorsqu'il voit la
caravane de louis xiv passé les français
peuvent apercevoir un somptueux carrosse
doré avec à son bord les trois reines
[Musique]
les trois reims c'est l'expression des
paysans qui sont éberlués de voir dans
le carrosse royal passée le roi la reine
mademoiselle de la manière et madame de
montespan et alors tout le monde salue
vive le roi vive le roi et le roy on le
dit est avec celle qui est et celles qui
n'osent pas être et celle qui met plus
et pour ces trois reines rien n'est
jamais trop beau
[Musique]
régulièrement louis xiv organise des
bals somptueux en leur honneur de grande
fête où l'on vient aussi admirer le roi
soleil l'approché est tenté de se faire
remarquer des balles à la mécanique
parfaitement huilée
[Musique]
et grand bal comme celui-ci louis xiv on
organise souvent il faut occuper les
courtisans et le roi adore danser le
protocole est toujours le même louis xiv
arrive au bras de son épouse marie
thérèse d'autriche mais celle ci va très
vite ça soir car elle n'aime pas à
danser
[Musique]
du coup les rênes de ces festivités sont
louise de la vallière ou encore madame
de montespan les maîtresses en titre car
elles savent bien mieux que la reine
divertir le roi et le reste de la cour
[Musique]
ces balles peuvent rassembler jusqu'à
600 personnes tout s'y passe un peu
comme en boîte de nuit aujourd'hui c'est
à dire qu'on y vient pour s'amuser pour
danser mais surtout pour se montrer car
le but de la vie d'un courtisan et de se
faire remarquer du roi de préférence en
bien
mais le sport national c'est la
médisance et la moquerie c'est
d'ailleurs souvent pendant ces balles
que sont colportées les nouvelles
rumeurs concernant les aventures
amoureuses du roi
c'est aussi le moment où l'on cherche à
ternir l'image de la favorite pour
prendre sa place évidemment
lors de ces grands bals le roi met donc
en scène les femmes de sa vie avec
beaucoup d'éclat en public il se montre
envers elle toujours prévenant galant et
charmeur
mais en privé louis xiv peut parfois
montré un tout autre visage plus cruel
celui là
ce fut le cas notamment avec louise de
la vallière
la scène se passe au château de saint
germain en laye
lavallière rey et le montespan avait des
appartements contigus il est vrai que le
roi vers 17 heures a traversé la chambre
de laval hier pour se rendre dans celle
de madame de montespan ce qui était
assez cruel
madame
cyr
[Musique]
qu'ai je fait à votre majesté pour
qu'elles doivent imposer ce jeu pourquoi
mme interdisez-vous de quitter la cour
du chef de la vallière l'épargné nous
cette scène n'oubliez pas que les
reproches sur le privilège de la reine
[Musique]
laura fait comme si je n'existais plus
qu est ce que je le fais
du chef de la vallière ne devraient pas
se plaindre j'adore les femmes comme je
l'entends je suis le roi et je fais ce
que l'on me semble
louis xiv pouvait parfois être même
parfaitement goujat il traverse la pelle
la chambre de la petite louise
lavallière avec un petit chien dans les
bras qu'il caresse et il se dirige vers
la chambre de madame de montespan et
puis il se dit bon allez je vais
directement chez madame de montespan il
envoie le chien sur le lit du louise en
lisant voilà amusez vous moi j'ai autre
chose à faire il ya un côté sultan son
harem et là son attitude n'est pas très
bon pour nous battre et pas très
heureuse
humilié louise de la vallière finira par
quitter la cour après treize années
passées aux côtés du roi dont 7 ou alors
a dû cohabiter avec sa rivale la
montespan
louise aura donné quatre enfants à louis
xiv deux seulement survivront
enfin je pars
j'ai consacré ma vie à dieu et lui
demander pardon pour tous les péchés que
j'ai commis
[Musique]
et chose incroyable
au moment de quitter la cour
mademoiselle de la vallière la maîtresse
ira aussi demandé pardon à la reine
marie thérèse d'autriche l'épousé
bafouée depuis tant d'années
votre majesté
je vous prie de bien vouloir me
pardonner pour toute la peine que j'ai
pu vous causer
cela fait bien longtemps que je vous ai
pardonné madame
pour expier ses péchés la duchesse
souhaite dorénavant entré dans les
ordres
contrainte d'abandonner ses deux enfants
à leur père les adieux sont déchirants
louis xiv lui reste impassible
c'est sa décision
à compter de ce jour la duchesse de
lavallière est morte pour moi
dès lors la duchesse de la vallière
devient soeur louise de la miséricorde
sa rivale évincer la montespan devient
la maîtresse un titre unique et
incontesté
d'ailleurs louis xiv va faire en sorte
qu'elle est le train de vie dignes d'une
reine
[Musique]
bienvenue à versailles si je suis ici
c'est pour vous montrer que louis xiv
veiller personnellement à ce que les
femmes de sa vie soit installée tout
près de lui pour pouvoir les rejoindre
en toute discrétion pour mieux
comprendre on va se rendre tout de suite
dans la chambre du roi juste ici au
premier étage
et la chambre du roy est situé au centre
du château
à gauche il y a les appartements de la
reine à droite ceux de madame de
montespan nous voici donc dans la
chambre du roi telle qu'elle était en
1701 je vais vous montrer maintenant le
trajet qu'il devait faire pour rejoindre
sa marquise favorite madame de montespan
suivez-moi
[Musique]
nous arrivons ici à la fin des
appartements privés de louis xiv et lui
suffisait de franchir cette porte pour
se retrouver chez madame de montespan
regarder l'immensité de ses appartements
des appartements digne d'une reine c'est
dire l'importance qu'elle avait pour le
roi
si louis xiv a veillé personnellement
installer sa maîtresse près de lui il
n'en a pas pour autant négliger la place
de son épouse dans le château
nous revoici donc dans la chambre du roi
louis xiv mais même après avoir passé du
bon temps avec ses maîtresses sa nuit ne
s'arrête pas là car tous les soirs il va
rendre visite à la reine pour accomplir
son devoir conjugal
[Musique]
c'est par ce corridor discret que tous
les soirs louis xiv venez retrouver son
épouse la reine marie thérèse
il lui suffisait d'ouvrir cette porte
pour se retrouver
dans la chambre de la reine
[Musique]
et il n'ya pas que dans le château que
louis xiv a fait aménager des espaces
dédiés à ses amours
à
l'extérieur le jardinier de versailles
le célèbre andré le nôtre a dû faire
preuve d'imagination
le parc de versailles regorge d'endroits
qu'aucun des dizaines de bosses qui
répartis un peu partout où le roi avait
pour habitude d'abriter ces amours loin
des regards de la cour
[Musique]
nous sommes ici dans le bosquet de lens
laddh conçus par le nôtre c'est l'un des
bosquets les plus coquins de jardins de
versailles et vous allez comprendre
pourquoi
[Musique]
c'est ici que louis xiv aimé retrouver
madame de montespan d'ailleurs tout est
fait pour préserver l'intimité des deux
amants d'abord cet ep feuillage qui les
protège des oreilles et des regards
indiscrets
et puis ces petits bancs installés un
peu partout dans des angles morts
quand on est louis xiv que l'on vit dans
un château surpeuplée que vous êtes
toujours à la merci d'une oreille ou
d'un regard indiscret le jardin offre de
bien belles perspectives pas seulement
visuel mais qui vous permettent
d'envisager un après-midi câlins avec
pourquoi pas madame de montespan
[Musique]
m
à versailles madame de montespan savoure
sa place de favorite royal elle fait
bien car cela ne va pas durer
car il est une autre femme qui va entrer
en scène
[Musique]
et pas des moindres puisqu'il s'agit
d'une gouvernante qui aura la lourde
tâche de s'occuper des enfants que
madame de montespan aura avec le roi
je voudrais votre majesté instamment
vous recommander une femme qui pourrait
élever cas chez nos futurs enfants
[Musique]
cette femme fait madame scaron elle
deviendra célèbre plus tard sous le nom
de madame de maintenon
[Musique]
est ce que cette personne et si l'aide
qu'elles doivent se dissimuler
je m'appelle françoise caron je suis né
en prison
mon mari était le célèbre scaron impôts
est brillant mais difformes
je suis veuve à présent
je vous avait sous-estimé madame
quand madame de montespan elle a recruté
pour s'occuper des enfants comme
gouvernante bon c'est un poste
subalterne presque un post de domestique
et d'autres pas bon il n'était pas
imaginable pour la sultane rennes que
cet obscur veuve puisse devenir une
rivale pour elle elle l'a choisi parce
que justement c'était quelqu'un
d'absolument insignifiants qu'ils ne
comptaient pas
[Musique]
madame de montespan a eu la
bienveillance de me prendre à son
service pour que je m'occupe de l'enfant
qu'elle aura avec le roi à cet instant
je n'imagine pas ce que le destin va me
réserver
[Musique]
la marquise de montespan va donner au
roi de nombreux enfants sept au total
dont quatre atteindront l'âge adulte
mais au départ personne ne doit
soupçonner que louis xiv puisse en être
le géniteur
en effet il est impensable pour un roi
de france lui-même marier d'avoir des
enfants avec une femme elle aussi marié
fut-elle marquise
[Musique]
alors madame scaron va devoir élever les
bâtards du roi à l'abri des regards ici
dans cette maison discrète de la rue de
vaugirard à paris
au fur et à mesure des naissances mme
adams car on se rend à la cour la nuit
tombée dans la plus stricte discrétion
chercher les nouveau nés
[Musique]
seulement très vite les relations entre
madame de montespan et madame scaron
vont se détériorer car la gouvernante ne
supporte pas le désintérêt affiché de la
marquise à l'égard de ses enfants
[Musique]
si
madame
je viens vous annoncer une bien triste
nouvelle
votre fille n'a pas survécu
elle est morte dans mes bras au petit
matin nous infliger armada nous en
ferons d'autres
[Musique]
des tensions sont très
divers ne font que s'accroître louis xiv
essaye d'intervenir et de calmer le jeu
donnant souvent raison à madame de
maintenon donc ce qui évidemment à vivre
la fureur de madame de montespan
la rivalité entre les deux femmes né à
cet instant là mais pour l'heure madame
scaron future madame de maintenon qui
n'est que gouvernante a choisi de se
taire cela n'aura qu'un temps
[Musique]
le 20 décembre 1673 le roi se décide à
légitimer les bâtards né de sa liaison
avec la marquise de montespan du coup
madame scaron la gouvernante vient
officiellement s'installer à versailles
pour s'occuper d'eux et c'est par
l'intermédiaire des enfants qu'elle va
conquérir le coeur du roi
[Musique]
et c'est parce qu'elle aimait ses
enfants parce qu'elle est attachée en
particulier à l'aîné d'entre eux le
petit duc du maine qui avaient des
problèmes de rachitisme ils marchaient
très difficilement l'a cru à un moment
donné qui ne marcherait pas et c'est
elle qui l'emmenait faire une cure et à
ramener triomphalement l'enfant marchand
et louis xiv en a été infiniment
reconnaissants aux assauts l'oeil porte
au monde la guerre
fortune l'hydrater pas et la foudre de
jupiter t'apportera la victoire
[Musique]
louis xiv apprécié la façon dont la
gouvernante s'occupe de ses enfants il
aime aussi son intelligence et sa
discrétion
[Musique]
du coup ils passent de plus en plus de
temps avec elle ils vont se rapprocher
de plus en plus à partir de son entrée à
la cour de versailles et puis elle va
d'abord acquérir l'estiment du roi et
puis au fil des discussions son amitié
et puis elle va devenir sa confidente
où je peux les excuses mais force10
ailleurs des médias
[Musique]
et
c'est ainsi au fil du temps que madame
scaron va devenir la nouvelle maîtresse
de louis xiv
[Musique]
mais la menace
c'est
pendant des années l'idylle entre le roi
et madame scaron va rester secrète
mais madame de montespan n'est pas dupe
elle constate une complicité
inhabituelles entre louis xiv et la
nourrice très vite la marquise se montre
jalouse envers madame scaron désormais
sa rivale
quand madame de montespan a su que louis
xiv
voulait être du dernier bien avec la
nourrice de ses enfants la prise a très
mal elle avait des jurons par madame
scaron les torcher le cul disait d'elle
à propos de cette fin il a le sentiment
que depuis quelques temps les choses
changent quel est écarté de plus en plus
de louis xiv avec une autre femme mme
adams car on a de plus en plus
d'influencé droit
la tension entre la gouvernante et
madame de montespan grandit de jour en
jour
les disputes se multiplient et
deviennent même parfois violentes à
l'image de cette scène du pot de crème
nous sommes dans les appartements de
madame de montespan celle ci a demandé à
sa gouvernante madame scaron de l'aider
à se préparer la rivalité entre les deux
femmes est à son comble et c'est à cause
de ce pot de crème qu'une violente
dispute va éclater
madame scaron alerte madame de montespan
sur l'état de santé de ces enfants
qu'elles jugent préoccupant et madame de
montespan ne l'écoutent pas plus
préoccupé par sa beauté que par le sort
de sa progéniture en progrès mais encore
la petite mademoiselle de nantes ne
mange pas à fait je ne sais pas quoi
faire vous devriez en informer le roi
vous ne m'écoutez pas
quel malheur
il va bien falloir un mois avant qu'il
ne soit remplacé
vous l'avez fait exprès je sais
je ne suis pas votre suivante regardez
je suis trop maladroite
elle me prend pour sa bonne c'est
insupportable je suis furieuse cette
femme que j'ai choisi et qui je confie
l'éducation mes enfants se permet une
telle insolence
[Musique]
et madame de montespan est une femme qui
sait comment elle est arrivée qui sait
ce qu'elle a dû faire pour gagner
justement là
l'amour du roi et qui doit se rendre
compte qu'effectivement son amour est en
train de s'effriter elle va se rendre
compte que quelque chose se trame elle a
peur pour elle pour son avenir et à
juste titre
[Musique]
manquait pas d'audace
c'était plus fort que moi je les gifles
et elle semble oublier qu' elle est ce
qu'elle me doit elle est hystérique un
jour je suis sa femme de chant le
lendemain sa pire ennemie et le jour
d'après son ami a plus cher sans et trou
madame scaron sans cesse humilié par
madame de montespan ne pense plus qu'à
une chose maintenant quitté la cour
alors pour l'en dissuader le roi va lui
donner 250 mille livres une somme
rondelette à l'époque puisque ainsi la
gouvernante va pouvoir s'offrir un
château
village de maintenon à une cinquantaine
de kilomètres du château de versailles
nous sommes au château de maintenon en
eure-et-loir à une heure de paris une
magnifique demeure que la veuve car on a
pu s'offrir après cinq années passées au
service du roi
oh
mais plus que le château c'est un nombre
que le roi va offrir à la gouvernante de
ses enfants à la surprise générale il
l'a fait marquise c'est à dire qui lui
donne à elle qui est née au fond d'une
prison le même rang que la montespan
voici donc pour la gouvernante une
occasion unique de se venger des années
d'humiliation que lui a fait subir sa
rivale
[Musique]
et voici comment louis xiv en seulement
quelques mots va changer le destin de sa
gouvernante madame scaron et cela devant
une madame de montespan médusés
votre majesté puis je me retirais
je vous sers gré infinie de toutes les
choses que vous faites pour mon service
madame de maintenon
[Musique]
madame de maintenon madame de maintenon
la nouvelle cour est déjà dans les
corridors les paliers les salons du
château je n'ai qu'un seul regret ne pas
pouvoir me jeter publiquement au pied du
roi pour lui marquer toute ma
reconnaissance
que je l'appelle madame de maintenon
elle ces tissus valterne il en est hors
de question je crois que madame de
montespan qualifiait la maintenon de
guenon clé peut même pas très aimable
comme on peut-on s'imaginer quand on
s'appelle malades de maps de montespan
être mises sur la touche par une guenon
la messale côté de quelque chose de
terrible
madame de maintenon a presque tout gagné
un château un titre maintenant il ne lui
reste plus qu'à se débarrasser de son
éternel rival la marquise de montespan
et pour cela elle va se trouver un allié
de poids dieu
[Musique]
versailles avril 1675 nous sommes en
pleines fêtes de pâques tous les sujets
du roi et le monarque lui-même doivent
avant la grande messe se confesser et
c'est là que tout va basculer pour
madame de montespan car ce qu'elle
ignore c'est que madame de maintenon
fait partie d'un petit groupe
d'ecclésiastiques bien décidé à
provoquer la rupture entre louis xiv et
la marquise et la mission pourrait-on
dire de ce groupe c'est de remettre le
roi dans le droit chemin de la vertu et
d'obtenir la promesse du roi d'une
rupture définitive avec madame de
montespan
jusqu'à présent l'église s'était résigné
au comportement libertins du roi mais
cette fois ci un prêtre le père l'écuyer
vais y mettre un terme et voilà comment
il va s'y prendre
le 10 avril 775 celle mercredi sa madame
de montespan
va elle aussi se confesser à versailles
dans la ville de versailles
finissais mon père parce que j'ai péché
je ne rêve pas est ce là cette madame de
montespan qui scandalise toute la france
allez madame
ccvo scandale vous viendrez vous j'étais
au pied des ministres de jésus-christ
[Musique]
on lui refuse l'absolution et ça c'est
une manoeuvre de sa rivale à mme de
maintenon naturellement en refusant
l'absolution à madame de montespan
l'église désigne aux yeux du peuple la
marquise comme la responsable de la
débauche du roi de france elle doit donc
quitter la cour et louis xiv promet
dorénavant de retrouver le chemin de la
vertu
le malheur d une fait le bonheur des
autres madame de montespan pleurs de
devoir quitter la cour madame de
maintenon jubile
je suis heureuse que le roi ait pris la
bonne décision il fallait le remettre
sur le droit chemin il a décidé de
quitter madame de montespan
pour la première fois depuis son
adolescence le roi entre dans une phase
d'abstinence sexuelle seulement cela ne
va pas durer bien longtemps
un an plus tard louis xiv de retour de
la guerre est pris à nouveau d'une
irrésistible frénésie sexuelle
il renoue avec celle qui n'a jamais
quitté son coeur la pulpeuse marquise de
montespan celles qui avaient été bannis
par l'église revient à versailles
les retrouvailles sont fougueuse au
diable les bondieuseries
dieu
vous savez qu'une reviendrai ce ne
sourions vivre l'un sans l'autre
le retour en grâce de madame de
montespan n'arrive pourtant pas à
assouvir les pulsions royal alors le roi
fait passer dans son lit une ribambelle
de femmes de la cour
les maîtresses vont se succéder à un
rythme effréné
elle s'appelle anne julie de rohan
chabot princesse de soubise claude de 20
des oeillets
marie-elisabeth de ludres
elisabeth hamilton conteste de grammont
diane-gabrielle damas de tihange
duchesse de nevers est ce parce qu'il
sent qu'il vieillit que le roi multiplie
les aventures toujours est-il qu'il
retrouve à cette époque une seconde
jeunesse
vers l'âge de 40 ans démon de midi en
quelque sorte l' appétit sensuel de
louis xiv n'a plus de bord tout lui
était bon pourvu que ce fussent des
femmes des paysannes des jardinières des
femmes de chambre etc et il est vrai que
le 14 à cette époque va multiplier ce
qu'on appelait des passades et parmi ces
façades il y à une jeune fille qui va
faire parler d'elle ce sera la dernière
favorite de louis xiv elle s'appelle
angélique de fontanges elle a 18 ans et
elle est très belle
cette jeune fille très très ambitieuse
n'est pas très intelligent pour tout le
monde y est les soldes convainc pas nier
malgré tout mademoiselle de fontanges se
retrouve enceinte du roi et cela lui
sera fatal
elle va mourir dans des souffrances
terribles et l'ombre de montespan
d'ailleurs va planer parce que beaucoup
de pense que mademoiselle de fontanges à
peut-être été empoisonné mademoiselle de
fontanges arrive une époque madame de
montespan et pratiquement sur la touche
pour ne pas dire sur la touche et je
crois que l'idée que nouvelles jeunes
qui arrivent serait vraiment exclure
définitivement madame de montespan un
témoin capital va d'ailleurs venir
corroborer les soupçons qui pèsent sur
madame de montespan la fille de la
voisins une sorcière bien connu du tout
paris fait un aveu troublant sa mère
aurait fourni à la marquise de la poudre
mortels destinée empoisonné mademoiselle
de fontanges pour que sa favorite ne
soient pas inquiétés le roi décide de
mettre un terme aux rumeurs et ceux qui
accusent la montespan seront châtiés
[Musique]
des instructions très précises vont être
donnés pour que tous ceux qui ont cité
le nom de madame de montespan ceux là
vont être enfermés dans des citadelles
de province par lettre de cachet ils
vont rester là 10 15 20 ans 30 ans même
dans des prisons l'afer est étouffée
pour louis xiv
cependant le mal est fait car même si
madame de montespan et de fait innocente
et le roi quand même des doutes sur son
implication il va donc la répudier mais
en y mettant tout de même les formes
qu'est-il arrivé au roi il ne me regarde
plus
les splendeurs de la cour a disparu
chaque rire se meurt en la présence de
madame de maintenon
une seule couleur règne désormais sur la
cour sa couleur
noire
[Musique]
la marquise est une femme intelligente
elle comprend qu'elle n'est plus la
favorite du roi et que désormais une
seule femme compte dans le coeur de
louis xiv
madame de maintenon
vous resterez ici et vivre est près de
moi je vous rendrai visite chaque jour
elle n'espérait pas que nous restions
seule relation n'existeront que pour la
n'attendais rien de moi madame bien
d'autres que ma courtoisie je dois jouer
le rôle maintenant qu'auparavent allons
chers amis personne ne connaît mieux que
vous la règle du jeu bordeaux n'est moi
madame je ne supporte pas votre parfum
aujourd'hui il me procure des maux de
tête
[Musique]
si louis xiv consent à garder la
marquise à versailles c'est uniquement
parce que cette femme lui a fait sept
enfants elle restera encore dix ans
auprès de lui le souverain lui donnera
le coup de grâce en lui demandant de
quitter ses somptueux appartement le
signe de la disgrâce c'est lorsque louis
xiv demande à madame de montespan de
quitter semble appartement avec cinq
fenêtres sur la cour de marbre pour
descendre en héritage
[Musique]
la marquise de montespan quittera
définitivement versailles en 1691 pour
aller se réfugier dans un couvent et y
faire pénitence de sa vie de débauche
30 juillet 1683 la reine marie thérèse
d'autriche meurt à versailles à l'âge de
45 ans d'une septicémie foudroyante
une femme dont l'histoire retiendra
surtout sa dignité face à l'un des rois
les plus volages que la france ait connu
quand marie thérèse d'autriche est morte
on prête à 1014 ses mots c'est bien là
le seul chagrin qu'elle m'ait jamais
posée c'est pas très gai est ce ainsi
que l'on résume une vie entière avec une
femme je ne suis pas sûr qu'il est mais
je crois qu'ils sont satisfaisants et je
pense que cette femme a dû souffrir
souffrir de voir que le roi se détourner
d'elle
mais à seulement 45 ans le roi ne va pas
rester veuve très longtemps
deux mois plus tard dans le plus grand
secret
louis xiv épouse madame de maintenon
pour autant l'ancienne gouvernante ne
deviendra jamais reine de france car
d'origine modeste elle n'est pas de sang
royal
avec l'avènement de madame de maintenon
versailles prend un visage austère à son
image fini les libertinage place à une
vie plus sobres presque monacale
avec ce mariage louis xiv ne trompe plus
n'a plus le vie dissolue n'a plus de
maîtresse à droite et à gauche il a son
épouse devenue légitime madame de
maintenon elle va veiller sur son mari
un petit peu comme une petite mamie elle
va vieillir gentiment à côté du roi qui
va le dire gentiment et elle va veiller
sur lui ne prenait pas froid voilà ça
cesse ça n'est plus du tout le roi
soleil
c'est une éclipse gigantesque
pendant encore près de 30 ans louis xiv
et madame de maintenon vont couler des
jours paisibles presque comme monsieur
et madame tout le monde
l'occasion pour le roi de revoir défiler
les grands moments de sa vie
sa mère qui a fait de lui un grand homme
d'innombrables maîtresse et plus d'une
quinzaine d'enfants illégitimes
[Musique]
dieu
costumes
c'est vrai un
château le plus grand du monde
un règne de plus de 70 ans record de
longévité parmi les rois de france
il ya une chose qui est terrible lorsque
louis xiv est petit on guette d'ailleurs
la porte de sa chambre des murmures
d'avant d'un éventuel plaisir puéril
lorsque louis xiv de vierges jeunes
mariés on guettait à la porte un soupir
de plaisir et bien quand il devient
vieux d'autres personnes toujours
derrière la porte essai de gaieté
l'expression d'un soupir mais cette fois
ci un soupir de trépas c'est terrible
cet homme finalement à des gens qui tous
les jours simple et nous lui sourit des
gens qui n'attendent qu'une chose sa
mort pour savoir auprès de clips devront
demain s'incliner c'est terrible
le 1er septembre 1715 le roi soleil
meurt des suites d'une gangrène
fulgurante
il allait avoir 77 ans
[Musique]
le roi
à
[Musique]
pour la deuxième fois de sa vie madame
de maintenon et veuve
elle quitte la cour pour s'installer à
saint cyr près de versailles et y
demeurer jusqu'à sa mort en 1718
[Applaudissements]
alors qui pour succéder au roi soleil
puisque à sa mort ni son fils ni ses
petits fils ne sont encore en vie c'est
finalement cet enfant qui va monter sur
le trône louis 15 l'arrière petit fils
de louis xiv il règnera sur la france
pendant près de soixante ans est à
l'image de son célèbre
arrière-grand-père collectionnera comme
lui d'innombrables metref
[Musique]